about 30,000 stakeholders representing
the interests of corporations NGOs think
tanks public authorities trade business
or professional associations are based
in Brussels some of them walk in and out
of the EU institutions every day they're
able to shape policies that match the
needs and realities of citizens
businesses and other organizations in
the Member States it's a practice that
dates back to the 1830s when groups
representing private interests used to
roam the lobbies in the House of Commons
in London to put their case to MPs to
answer European citizens concerns about
the independence of EU institutions a
European transparency register was
created in 2011 this is an online public
database where organizations have to
register and are invited to declare who
they are who they represent what they
want and how much they've spent on
lobbying entries must be accurate
complete and up-to-date and all those on
the register must sign a code of conduct
every new organisation asking for
registration will be checked and can be
removed if there's a complaint
I hope 2016 over 9,000 stakeholders
registered in return they can access the
EU institutions premises to meet civil
servants commissioners and MEP s and sit
on expert panels transparency register
ensures greater scrutiny of lobbying
covering both the lobbyist and of the
civil servants and anybody's who meet
them but lobbyists do not comply with
the specified code of conduct they lose
their access to the EU authorities the
European Parliament and European
Commission use the transparency register
the console acts merely as an observer
finally in continuing efforts to
increase transparency and openness in
the EU policymaking process the
Parliament is calling on the Commission
to make the registration of stakeholders
mandatory by 2017